la première fois aux césars les
meilleurs effets visuels pour la
première fois
[Musique]
ah oui c'était beau et aux effets
visuels aussi voici mon cul
donc le voir rien hommage à la q tu sais
tu es ma petite déclaration d'amour à
moi
aussi des mains et surtout
à louis garrel que j'aime
louis oui coupé mois la parole couper la
parole je t'aime louis le message est
passé merci merci mon mari son fils je
crois voilà c'était un peu ma vie digne
voilà donc c'est un
rien mais ça devrait après moi j'irai
moi je la kiffe marie sérieux voilà
après c'est vrai que c'est assez
compliqué à la voulait c'est possible de
faire un jour une cérémonie sans que ce
soit systématiquement avec de la
vulgarité pour faire du buzz c'était pas
de
revient à l'horrible deux mois ces deux
choses qui m'ont dérangé celle-là
automne au code parfait et puis la
deuxième chez un peu d'accord avec
bernard où étaient les stars où étaient
les jean dujardin et
j'adore il avait 2-3 et gilles mai pour
décider laisser derrière nous et qu'il y
avait de longs il examen lui pas
souhaité les stars
c'était un peu de marche a manqué deux
stars et puis et puis et puis j'ai vu de
cette vulgarité keitel mais pour le
reste c'était bien alors gilbert je
trouve mes collègues très dur moi je
vais vous dire j'ai retrouvé le plaisir
de regarder les césar j'ai trouvé que
c'était assez chic que c'était élégant
que de caunes était formidable il ya eu
de la variété dans les récompensés car
ils ont beau long mais j'ai trouvé que
c'était voilà on purgeait les erreurs du
passé on repartait sur un bon pied mais
pardon mais j'ai le choix de la paix à
pénible si c'est pas très joli l'olympia
le plat du châtelet c'était magnifique
la côte on regarde l olympiakos a été
caméras ses
abonnés moi je voudrais pas indulgent
moi je me suis ennuyé mais vraiment
énormément j'ai trouvé évidemment de
caunes est formidable et il fait ce
qu'il peut mais je trouvais que c'était
long que c'était poussif à 00h10 on
passe aux choses sérieuses avant on est
complètement coupé du système dassault
ne fait pas de quoi de quoi il en
retourne donc c'est un vrai con et je
trouve que surtout la salle en fait on
parle d'artistes on parle de comédiens
ont ils doivent être généreux j'ai
trouvé que la salle n'était pas
généreuse elle se marre pas elle part
pas d'eau les délires il ya un hommage à
jean paul belmondo personnes se lèvent
bah oui
sow lui ça serait bien qu'on sait
pourquoi une blanquette et c'est
formidable mais jean-paul helmand dans
le plus grand acteur de tous les temps
en france voit et on se lève pas ils
sont comme ça tours ans comme ça c'est
pas généralement d'accord avec gérad
gêne les gens
omar sy qui fait un petit tour à
personne se lève on bouge un peu là
dessus ici les gens bougent et gérard
gili s'est pas généreux